- WELCOME, FOLKS, TO THE GREAT MVP RACE.
- Deshaun Watson, Clemson.
- Christian McCaffrey, STANFORD.
- Lamar Jackson, YOUR NIGHTMARES.
- Russell Wilson, I’m your mom’s favorite.
- Michael Thomas, THE only receiver in THE race.
- And in the back is everyone who’s kind of in the conversation.
- Aaron Jones, UTEP
- Kirk Cousins, my heart
- Dalvin Cook, Florida State
- Aaron Rodgers.
- MR. JONES, I NEED FUEL.
- Eh, let’s see how you do without the fuel to see how much fuel we should give you.
- RUSS TAKES AN EARLY LEAD.
- And he’s doin’ it while carrying his entire team.
- But Lamar is in second after some trouble with the Browns and the Chiefs.
- Russ is clearly ahead, but maybe Lamar should win because of how he’s
new and way more fun.
- I’M WEARING SUNGLASSES WHEN IT DOESN’T MAKE SENSE TO.
- Now, the race is tougher for non-QBs.
- Yo, this doesn’t seem fair.
- MICHAEL THOMAS IS BREAKING BARRIERS, BUT NO ONE IS LOOKING!
- CAN’T GUARD MIKE.
GUARDRAIL, MIKE!
- And KYLE ALLEN HAS DRIVEN CMC OFF A CLIFF!
- WHO’S GONNA WIN NOW?!
Good thing this is a two-minute episode.
- Let’s all say what we’re thankful for.
- PS4!
- Same. Let’s eat.
PS4 starting at $199!
- Looks like MAHOMES IS ENTERING THE RACE DESPITE
MISSING SO MUCH TIME.
- PATRICK MAHOMES, HATCHED FROM A FOOTBALL.
- Way ahead, Russ has a power-up, and IT’S THE 12th MAN.
- LAMAR DOESN’T HAVE THE NUMBERS.
- Uh, I guess it’s slightly louder than usual.
- Deshaun Watson’s got BULLET BILL O’BRIEN.
- WHO NEEDS A FRONT OFFICE?!
- No offense, but you made it harder for me to win.
- Hey, put on some Creed.
- NO.
- I have to pee.
- WE ARE IN A RACE.
- What’s this? LAMAR’S GOT A PURPLE SHELL.
- This reminds me of how Mike Vick used to turn into a shell and hit his opponents.
- I think he’ll get hurt racing like that.
- Shut up, Tess.
- Ugh! Think, Russ. What does Ciara always say?
- I’m only gonna stay in Seattle if you dress better.
- No, not that. The other thing.
- Automatic.
Supersonic.
Hypnotic. Funky Fresh.
- LET ME DO THE ONE-TWO STEP.
- YOU THINK THAT’S IMPRESSIVE?! HA HA.
- I WILL WIN MVP.
- HEY, GUYS! WHY ARE WE ALL racing?
- What’s coming down the Ma-home stretch?
- OH, I ALREADY WON THIS. NEVER MIND.
- I’M RUSSELL WILSON, AND I’M JUST SO CONSISTENT!
- HA HA.
- AND LAMAR WINS—this lap. ONLY TWO MORE MONTHS OF MVP RACE COVERAGE.
- If you
- LIked
- This video
- Subscribe below
- For more.
- Or we’re not
- Jason
- And Jason McCourtey.
- No, you’re Devin.
- I’m pretty sure you’re Devin.
- Which of us is Devin?
- Uh, you.
- ME?
- I’ll be Devin.
- Thanks Jason.